Good afternoon everyone, my name is Ben Busby
and I am the genomics outreach coordinator
for NCBI. In the next 5 to 7 minutes I will
show you four different ways to get data from
the Genome in a Bottle project.
With me, virutally, I have the head of the
education group, Peter Cooper and Justin Zook,
a primary investigator at NIST who really
spearheads the Genome in a Bottle project.
This consortium is a collaboration between
NIST, FDA, NCBI and a whole bunch of other
people including volunteers to make data on
which one can benchmark bioinformatics and
sequencing methodologies and look for regions
with questionable variant calls and also to
identify high confidence variants.
In the next 5 to 7 minutes I will show you
four ways to get the data and if you have
any questions please type them into the question
pod.
One very quick way to get the data at NCBI
is to go to the Genome in a Bottle BioProjects.
If we were to expand this out we would see
a large abstract of what this is, and also
there is a link to the dedicated FTP site
which I will show you at the end that has
the cutting edge Genome in a Bottle data as
well as variant calls done by NIST and some
other groups.
The Genome in a Bottle data that is in BioProject
and SRA currently has 13 BioSamples and when
you look at these here you see that some are
from the 1000 genomes project and there are
other trios from other projects such as the
PGP.
Also you can look at the SRA experiment associated
with the Genome in a Bottle project. You can
see a list here. They are filterable using
Entrez filtering, and when we filter we can
look at the aligned datasets such as the Complete
Genomics dataset for the Ashkenazim Son. There
will be more aligned datasets coming into
the SRA in the next few weeks.
When we click on the actual SRA run we can
see the reference genome that it was aligned
to, the coverage and some other information
about the alignment. If you are interested
in streaming aligned data, please check out
the webinar we did on Feb 235. Also, unaligned
data and some aligned data can be investigated
using SRA blast. We did a webinar on that
last November 5 and please feel free to check
that out.
The other thing we can do with all of this
data is investigate the metadata by sending
these projects to the SRA run selector. This
run selector is SOLR-facetable resource where
one can look at available datasets that are
in SRA for many BioSamples included in the
Genome in a Bottle project. There are many
things that you can facet on. I've shown you
just a few that are faceting by BioSample
and platform.
Here we can see that we can filter by just
the Illumina and PacBio for one individual.
We can grab an accession list from that filtering
and we can use this to loop over using the
sra-toolkit if we want to stream data, particularly
parts of the genome or gene loci. These are
very useful, in my opinion, for benchmarking
algorithms without downloading and mapping
the entire genome.
Another place one can get genotype calls from
some of the Genome in a Bottle data, although
it is not necessarily a primary source of
the Genome in a Bottle datam is from the GetRM
project. We have links here directly to some
of the vcf and bed files produced by the NIST
group and there is also an associated FTP
site where we see variant calls from a bunch
of different groups. The project also has
a browser in which we can look at specific
genes and some of the variant calls.
I would just like to show you in the next
20 or 30 seconds some features of this browser.
You can see variant calls done by a number
of different groups as well as a genotype
browser where you can see where the calls
agree.
There is pretty good concordance between groups
for most genomic regions.
The most authoritative place to get Genome
in a Bottle data is from the Genome in a Bottle
FTP site. If you look at the README.ftp_structure
there is an updated outline of where you can
get all of the data sets including recently
updated data.
If you go a little bit farther into the data
you can see data broken out by specific BioSamples
and by going into analysis one can go ahead
and get the genotype calls for some of these
individuals.
One can get the latest data by going into
ftp/release/*/latest/ and you can get calls
as well as bed files from that location.
If you'd like to get involved in this Genome
in a Bottle project, some ways you could help
are by generating structural variants for any
of the Ashkenazim trio and compare and integrate
those calls that you submit. You can compare
and integrate phasing and also give feedback
as we see some of these high confidence calls.
If you are interested in getting involved
you can contact me, BenBusby at nih.gov or
Justin.Zook at nist.gov.
With that what we would like to do is open
the floor up to questions.
So, some people are having trouble accessing
the trace website. And I have been asked to
restate it. The quickest way to find an accurate
URL is to go to NCBI BioProjects, search for
Genome in a Bottle, find that BioProject and
expand the abstract. ftp-trace.ncbi.nih.gov/giab/ftp/
Another question that I think is more appropriate
for Justin is, are there any plans to liftover
to GRCh38?
That's a good question and we have talked
a lot about this. Our plans are generally
to make calls on GRCh37 (hg19) first. We are
working on methods to make calls on GRCh38
as well. We hope to have initial snp and indel
calls in the next 4 to 6 months probably.
Those will probably be without using the Alt
sequences initially, but we are interested
in using methods for the Alts.
Another person asks, what level of concordance
do you generally expect to see now when looking
only at snps and short indels?
This really depends a lot on exactly what
you are looking at. If you are looking in
the easier regions of the genome you can really
see very close to 100% concordance as long
as you have good coverage. When you start
getting to more difficult regions there is
often high discordance. Numbers that I often
see if you take two different bioinformatics
algorithms or two different sequencing technologies
then you have somewhere around 5 to 10% disagreement
between the two methods over the whole genome.
If down select to the easier portions of the
genome, you can really have close to 100%
concordance.
A more straightforward and fun question, have
there been samples deposited from the X Ten
Illumina platform?
I don't think there have quite yet but I know
some people have been generating these and
I believe there is an X Ten data set from
the Garvan Institute that is available for
our pilot genome, NA12878. I think if you
search for them you will be able to find them.
And just to make sure that they are not talking about the 10X platform, which is often confusing.
I think they actually do mean the X Ten Illumina
platform. But the 10X data, 10
X Genomics, recently released data from NA12878 and
the Ashkenazim trio. It's all available on
the FTP site.
All right, once again, if you have any other
questions about things that we have covered
such as BioProjects or Alts, please free to
check out our archived webinars, subscribe
to our YouTube channel or email me the questions
or email questions to webinars at ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
Thank you very much everybody and we will
see you soon for other NCBI webinars.